right now
I don't want anyone to know but us
so we're using our phones to film it
this is a private conversation that I
need private I need it to stay private
for now
this is hard it's a hard thing and I
want us all five of us
to hear it and just us kind of create a
little bubble for us and
let us just think about it
okay so I need to talk to you guys for a
long time it's true about with you
moving out of your house
I might figure it out the best time ever
no secret that Cody and I have been in a
rough spot for a long time
and I
have decided to leave I'm Gonna Leave
Cody
just leave
it's a hard decision
I need to make a choice for happiness I
need to make a choice
to have joy in my life and
peace
there hasn't been a lot of Hope at all
until I decided to leave
I feel strongly this is the best choice
for me
so worried this is what you were going
to talk about yeah
I know you uh packed a stop off I mean I
knew that but I didn't know
how final it was or if it was just a
break or something now it's final
I I mean just I'm in shock I don't
really know what to say here I don't
know what to say to her
um
I can't tell I don't know I get I can't
it's not really Computing really it's
not really ah it's just not making sense
right now I don't know what to say
this is this is just
um a big
foreign
like I'm not I I
don't even know I'm just processing at
this point
so I I mean I look I intellectually have
known this was coming
but here we are today and it's it's hard
to know something and then to have it
actually happen
[Music]